i hate intros but you guys are here to
find out what you need to know about how
not summoned to demon lord season one so
what do you need to know well pretty
much nothing i mean
technically this isn't like a really
dense plotline that you're gonna
struggle to follow along with but i
did promise three video formats for
every season that i covered so because
of that we're gonna cover it anyways it
has the most generic possible intro for
anisakai with the main character being
teleported inside of his favorite video
game becoming his in-game character
known as diablo now the first thing that
every isakai has to address
is whether they're going to explain how
the main characters switch worlds they
could address it sometime down the line
but as
of right now throughout season 1 they
don't really talk about it too much
all we know is that tits and pipsqueak
over here wanted a shiny new demon so
they perform some sort of summoning
ritual and for whatever reason he showed
up as his character speaking of tits and
pipsqueak we have
rem and shira who are the supporting
characters in the series that are going
to be joining diablo on his adventures
it'd be kind of awkward if they couldn't
control their shiny new summons so they
decided that they're gonna cast
an enslavement spell on diablo to force
his cooperation once he had arrived one
of diablo's key items that makes him so
powerful is the demon lord's ring he got
the ring in cross reverie by defeating
the demon lord of the brain
ank volos and has the ability to deflect
all magic back onto the caster
so when the girls cast the enslavement
spell it's reflected back
on them boom 1800 style lottery sets in
and he has two brand new
slaves this becomes the driving force
behind why the three stick together
because they're working to find
some way to break the enslavement ritual
and set the girls free they have an
assortment of side characters that are
going to be helping him out along the
way and the first one we come across
is celestine baudelaire who is the head
of the mages association in the city of
ultra celestine and rem are very close
and celestine feels the need to protect
rem because she has a demon lord
residing inside of her body diablo of
course
doesn't know this until they have some
sort of weird interaction where he
seduces her through
physical touch and then she's like oh
i'm so weak of the dies i'll just tell
you everything and then he learns the
entire story
after hearing this diablo vows to force
krep skull him out of rem's body and
defeat it this of course is the first
time that rem has been able
to share this with anybody because she
feared being rejected
or targeted so for diablo to learn this
about her and still accept her it really
means a lot
rem isn't the only one with a backstory
though when we find out that shira is a
princess from the kingdom of greenwood
she had fled from the kingdom because
her brother was trying to [ __ ] her two
other characters that are going to be
helping him out are emil bitchelberger
and sylvie burger doesn't play a huge
role in the show he just randomly shows
up to help out sometimes
sylvie is the guild master of the
adventurer's guild so if the gang needs
quests for money then she will be the
one who helps him out well diablo and
shira are on one of these quests we get
the introduction of the
fallen who are loyal to the demon lord
crept skull and wish to revive her
this of course means that they're
inevitably gonna target rem at some
point so diablo confronts an army of the
fallen who are going to attack a city
leading the army is the thick blonde
edelgard who tries to have a one-on-one
duel with diablo that wasn't in her best
interest since her
and the army of fallen she is leading
are easily defeated by him but because
she is hot she is kept alive which i
think is going to be a common theme
throughout the show if you want to [ __ ]
a character rest assured she probably
won't get killed off by these writers
especially if she's underage i can tell
the writers have a special place for
little kids in their hearts
or loins i'm not really sure but either
way they're probably safe with the army
of fallen taking care of the next
challenge revolves around
shira shira's father demands that faltra
handshira over or
war will be declared between the two
powers diablo goes to meet with the
leader of faultra city in
chester ray galford gaelford gives him
the quest of finding a way to prevent
the war and assigns another side
character to help him out which is how
the group first meets alicia
before they go to take care of that
matter they make a quick detour because
celestine may have found a way to break
the enslavement
meteos is a slave trader who teaches
them more about the enslavement that was
cast on the girls
she shows diablo a way to remove it but
it's very difficult and is gonna take a
lot of time
my money's on them never breaking the
enslavement because the color thing
seems like a weird fetish that the
writers are going with and i don't think
they're ever going to steer
away from that later that night the
group is approached by kira who is
shira's brother that had come looking
for her he's basically like hey you
gotta come up she's like ah [ __ ] that so
he tells her okay
sleep on it but i'm pretty sure at this
point she already knows that he's trying
to [ __ ] her to continue their bloodline
so i don't know why sleep would change
anything either you want to [ __ ] the
brother or you don't i'm just having a
hard time picturing somebody being kind
of wishy-washy on it and then going into
a deep sleep hit rem cycle a couple of
times
come out of it like maybe it's not such
a big deal whatever i'm just gonna [ __ ]
my brother it sounds like a good time i
don't know i was freaking out about it
look if you need sleep to decide if
you're gonna [ __ ] your brother or not
that sounds like an entirely independent
issue that you should work through first
back burner all of this enslavement
stuff because you're on the verge of
becoming a jerry springer character you
realize that right and you're worried
about a necklace are you [ __ ] kidding
me
the next day kira uses some sick tunes
to brainwash her into saying that she
wants to go home with him he's like
get in the [ __ ] carriage i love how
at no point shira thinks to say like oh
by the way my brother's trying to [ __ ]
me
anyway sweet dreams you couldn't find
one opening to say that it takes like 10
seconds and it seems kind of crucial
like oh guys hey kira's here by the way
he's trying to ruin the genetics in my
first born good luck and then we have
diablo who has his head so
far up his ass he can't figure out
what's going on he's just all moping
around like oh
this is so sad i really miss her i need
a pep talk to go get her back
no you don't need a pep talk you know
what you need you need two functioning
brain cells to figure out what's going
on here two
that's [ __ ] minimal they're just
sitting there making their little
potions and then you hear
the foot you can [ __ ] hear the flute
and then she stands up like it's time to
go hum to brother like give me a [ __ ]
break bro what
and then the girls come along they're
like hey yeah we should probably go get
her back
right and he's like okay the anime was
about to get like really good because of
a slimy tit reveal but then [ __ ]
comes in to ruin it sure gets saved by
diablo and then wants to keep kira alive
because they're still technically family
like oh we used to play kickball
together so i guess i can let the entire
incestuous rape thing slide
thankfully chester is there and he kills
him instead chester had decided it was
war so he was going to take
shira hostage but diablo prevents it and
defeats him
he doesn't kill him though so he still
could pop up in future seasons edelgard
makes her reappearance when she had
heard a rumor that krypt's golem is
residing inside of rem's body
she wants krupp's golem out of rem's
body so that she can worship it and it
can destroy all the mortal races all
that good stuff while diablo wants it
out of rom's body so that rem could be
free so since they have similar goals
they work together to get krebs golem
out of rem they made up three days later
so that diablo can perform a ritual
where he finger blast
the 14 year old's vagina so that he can
get the magic to corrupt golem i
just picture the focus group sitting
around like how can we get the mc to
finger this girl without the fans
getting upset and then that just the
glorious hero comes in
with like an ahagao shirt on and he's
just like
magic will use magic and they're like
oh [ __ ] everybody just [ __ ] hops up
like
oh [ __ ] takuma you're genius now before
we go for it like let's just stop here
what the [ __ ] is this like what is this
face
why do this what is this
like why would you make it weird but
then it gets better like let's back it
up a bit
what the [ __ ] is that what is that
animation
vaginas aren't like super glued together
man why does it open like that why do
this scene like this it's so weird
whatever i digress krebs golem is
summoned as an albino wally who doesn't
want to kill anybody
so they all become friends you guys
should have seen this coming though as
soon as i saw her character design i
knew the writers were never going to
kill her off
the writers are so hard for this girl
there's no way diablo's ever killing her
and we got euler rex who is the oldest
and strongest of the fallen and he shows
up to serve krupp's skull
now when he shows up he realizes that
krupp's golem is just kind of a normal
girl and not evil wanting to kill all
the mortal races or whatever so he
decides that the reincarnation
was incomplete so now he has to force
her to reincarnate so that she can reach
her final form diablo deters
lorex's attacks but he manages to escape
after the fight so he's gonna be showing
up a little bit later on even though
edelgard is technically a fallen she's
still loyal to lolly crept skollum so
she tags long back to the city but can't
go inside once i get back to the city
alicia who is working with edelgard
and the other fallen commenced their
master plan this plan
involves using a psychopathic paladin
named sadler to capture rem
and krep skull oasia had betrayed them
because she wants to set cups gollum
free in order to destroy
all of the mortal races however there
are some conditions krebskull must
experience an intense hatred which rem
is trying to prevent from happening when
sadler nearly kills rem in front of
krebs golem the event is traumatic
enough to trigger her transformation
she quickly takes revenge on sadler and
threatens to destroy
everything diablo and shira show up just
in time to revive ram using diablo's
healing potions
with her good as new krypt's gone calms
down and turns back into a lolly to
prevent something like this from
happening again diablo has to put an
enslavement spell onto krep's golem to
ensure the safety of everybody around
her
edelgard and alicia were targeted by
euler x and the other fallen because
their plan had failed forcing them to
flee into the city alicia gets edelgard
to crept skollum so that she could heal
her because edelgard was injured and
their escape the two of them are healed
and forgiven for their betrayal so they
rejoin the party also
i'm gonna be doing the next season and
you can find that on the left side
whenever i'm finished with it or you can
check out all the how to summon a demon
lord recaps in the playlist on the right
side you can also find the links in the
description below and the only thing i
hate more than intros is outros
you